bei mir im studio jetzt unser bild
politik chef jan schäfer gestern hat
sich paul hier schon ziemlich darüber
aufgeregt was da am ende bei
rausgekommen ist stundenlang wurde
gestritten und am ende was man muss es
so sagen wirklich gar nichts also
chaotisch chaotischer kanzler und kann
man wirklich sagen absolut richtig dass
was paul oder auch gestern gesagt hat
hat auch heute noch bestand mit einer
nacht dazwischen über die man dann noch
mal schlafen konnte in der man schlafen
konnte überall wo man nachdenken konnte
was da raus gekommen ist war wirklich
gar nichts
das kanzleramt das ist interessant hat
es wenn man meine an agonie aus dem
fußball
vielleicht nutzen möchte mit einem quasi
mit der kick and rush taktik versucht
erst die ministerpräsidenten am sonntag
in sicherheit gewogen wir machen gar
nicht viel es wird gar keine
verschärfung geben dann kam diese
beschlussvorlage um 22 uhr
das war quasi so der starke hohen ball
den mann von hinten vom tor nach vorne
schießt in der hoffnung dass sie irgend
ein stürmer ein tor dann versenkt aber
die mauer der ministerpräsidenten die
war einfach zu groß der widerstand viel
zu heftig und so ist das ganze dann als
pleite quasi zu ende gegangen ein großer
corona klatsche für die kanzlerin also
es gab gestern drei vorlagen und alle
drei wurden abgeschmettert am ende ist
dabei gar nichts rausgekommen und vor
allem interessant wer alle streiten
bequem hatte weil diesmal war es nicht
union gegen spd oder ein minister gegen
anderen sondern gefühlt alle gehen die
kanzlerin mal was ich da ziemlich
eigentlich dass man die pläne der
kanzlerin nicht gut findet das ging
morgens in der cdu präsidium schallte es
schon los das ist dort wo also das
spitzengremium der cdu mit den
ministerpräsidenten der cdu
zusammenkommen und schon da gab es den
ersten großen krach also armin laschet
beispielsweise war höchst unzufrieden
damit was er da bekommen hat und was ihm
da geboten wurde
dann gab es natürlich auch von der spd
seite viel viel krach und unmut und
generell ist die frage auch für solchen
vor solchen wichtigen gipfeln das ist ja
quasi eine atemlos politik die wir sehen
alle zwei wochen alle drei wochen wird
irgendwie alles wieder neu gemacht und
soll neu gemacht werden
da ist die frage wirklich ist es richtig
wenige stunden im vorfeld eigentlich
solche vorlagen zu verschicken
ich glaube es war viel wichtiger wenn
man da mehr zeit hätte das auch
ausreichend diskutieren könnte was hier
passiert ist das war eine nacht und
nebel aktionen die kanzlerin ihr
kanzleramtsminister 23 wissenschaft
haben sich etwas überlegt haben alle
anderen vorher daran nicht teil gelassen
und haben sie also sozusagen nicht
informiert und entsprechend frustriert
und ärgerlich sind natürlich die
ministerpräsidenten ja wir wollen jetzt
auch einmal eine stimme aus der eigenen
partei hören uns zugeschaltet professor
andreas schröder heute morgen sie sind
mitglied der cdu und aus den eigenen
kreisen gab sehr extreme kritik gestern
auch schon vor der eigentlich
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an der
kanzlerin
wie haben sie die vorlage für sich
entgegen genommen als sie zum ersten mal
gesehen haben und die pläne der
kanzlerin
guten morgen herr würzbach ja man weiß
ja gar nicht so ganz was man eigentlich
jetzt behalten soll und was man gleich
schon wieder vergessen kann und was
jetzt beschlossen worden ist
vielleicht ja auch eher eine lernaufgabe
in der schule was man denn jetzt
überhaupt behalten kann und was nicht so
ist das ganze hin und her gegangen das
heißt meine einschätzung ist schon die
dass der schäfer ja vollkommen recht hat
wenn er sagt das ist ein chaotisches
verfahren
es ist kein geregeltes politisches
verfahren aber geregelte politische
verfahren erleben wie sowieso im moment
in der pandemie kaum dieses ganze
verfahren zwischen der kanzlerin und den
ministerpräsidenten
das ist ja nichts was einem politisch
institutionalisierten einem regelmäßigen
oder regel entsprechenden politischen
gremium entspringen würde also insofern
war das schon ziemlich chaotisch auf der
einen seite auf der anderen seite aber
hat die kanzlerin ihre botschaft ihre
botschaft der besorgnis den eindruck
habe ich schon diese botschaft hat sie
gesetzt und was man zugleich feststellen
kann
es gibt ja nach wie vor kein
gegengewicht gegen das bundeskanzleramt
gegen die bundeskanzlerin in der
deutschen politik dass diese
unzufriedenheit die da über das
kanzleramt und die kanzlerin aufkommen
würde die diese unzufriedenheit wirklich
in politisches führungshand übersetzen
würde die kanzlerin regiert mit einer
art von teile und herrsche
und selbst wenn das gestern ziemlich
chaotisch war das funktioniert herr
professor da aber wie angeschlagen ist
die bundeskanzlerin nach dem gestrigen
gipfel acht das sagen wir ja im jahr
2020 ist nicht zum ersten mal herr
schäfer denken sie daran wie
angeschlagen die kanzlerin im februar
war bevor corona losgeht wir haben am
ende der ersten welle gesagt die
kanzlerin die kanzlerin sind ist das
heft des handelns von dem
ministerpräsidenten aus der hand
genommen worden
das stimmt ja auch im vorlauf zur
zweiten shut down hat die kanzlerin sich
auch nicht durchsetzen müssen aber sie
ist letztendlich doch immer da sie ist
die in der öffentlichkeit wahrgenommen
zentrale figur die kanzlerin ist zäh und
totgesagte leben länger und von daher
würde ich nicht darauf wetten dass das
jetzt ein nachhaltiger bedeutungsverlust
der bundeskanzlerin in der politik wäre
noch einmal
sie profitiert natürlich auch davon dass
es in der cdu im moment des führungs
vakuum gibt und dass ich kein
politisches gegengewicht gegen sie
etablieren kann
ein professor oder dass sie sich heute
morgen die zeit wenn diese einschätzung
genommen haben und jan zwei sachen die
ganz besonders diskutiert worden gestern
das ist einmal die schnupfen quarantäne
gewesen wäre es gerade unseren beitrag
und die ist jetzt erst mal gestrichen
die hätte ganze betriebe lahmlegen
können das heißt aber dass noch mal zu
erklären ich hätte ein bisschen höchsten
kratzen im hals und man hätte schon zu
hause bleiben ich hätte hier dann mit
mir selbst sprechen ich will genauso
umgekehrt wenn ich den stoff hätte hätte
ich dann zu hause bleiben müssen und
dann hättest du hier sozusagen mit dem
luftleeren raum gesprochen ganz genau
ist so richtig gab dann auch massive
kritik von seiten des bundes der
bundesvereinigung der
arbeitgeberverbände der präsident kramer
hat sich mit einem brief direkt an das
kanzleramt gewandt und hat gesagt also
das könne überhaupt nicht sein ganz klar
wir kommen jetzt in den winter wir sind
im herbst kommen in den winter viele
menschen haben einfach auch einmal ein
kratzen im hals ein kleiner schnupfen
und wenn man jetzt sagt plötzlich ihr
müsst alle zu hause bei mir das wird
eine ganze wirtschaft aber richtig lahm
denke dass wir dann der super lock down
und den kann natürlich überhaupt keine
rollen mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren